As the LHC has been working and running,
people are beginning to ask the question,
what comes next in the world of high energy physics.
Should that be another Collider?
And it's kind of become an issue for some people
because the large Hadron Collider, although it's doing fantastic science,
it's measuring quantities to amazingly high precision. If you think of it,
in terms of discovery of new particles, it's discovered one,
which was the Higgs back in 2012, which is what it was built for.
Exactly.
Really an incredible thing that happened in my lifetime.
It is not found anything else. It's not found any evidence of dark matter,
which throughs through the world of supersymmetry.
It's not found any evidence of more exotic things,
perhaps like extra dimensions are other new
particles. It has demonstrated that we cover effectively, uh,
an interaction between the Higgs and the Thermians,
a force acting there that we need to understand better because we can now probe
that regime, which we couldn't before. But the question is,
do we build an even bigger Collider?
And it was brought to a forefront by the, uh,
recent publication suggesting that there might be a,
what they call a future circular Collider best at sun.
That's where the current large Hadron Collider is.
The large Hadron Collider is underground in a ring that's about 25 kilometers
long.
The future circular Collider would be a ring that's a hundred kilometers long
four times the length.
It would cost the a 10 to 20 billion pounds.
Naturally a question that we need to ask ourselves both as physicists,
but also your society. You know,
where do you want to invest these large amounts of money?
There was a particular article that,
that at least within the particle physics community was read a lot by
Sabine Husson founder in which she said,
although she accepted that probing fundamental physics through
a particle accelerator is like the best microscope there is to do that.
The fact that we've only met this one discovery and we don't have any great
ideas as to what is coming next. In terms of theory,
perhaps we should be deferring building,
maybe not even building a future Collider until we have our theories firmly
better established. And then we can perhaps go ahead once we've said, well,
this is almost certainly to be, be the way forward. And, and,
and therefore that will dictate the form of any large Collider rather
than kind of fumbling in the dark. I think that's a,
probably she would agree with that, that the way that we,
if we go ahead right now, we are,
we best thing on physics that we already know,
but more speculative physics about what's coming next.
And so it's a really important question to address for me personally.
I think it's, uh, it's, uh, it's, there's not a clear cut answer.
I remember back in the 1980s,
when the large Hadron Collider was being put forward and maybe even slightly
earlier, people did think they knew what the solution was.
They did think that a dark matter would be found in what's known as wimps,
weakly interacting massive particles. There was,
we talked about a wimp miracle and there were natural candidates for this wimps,
which were coming from supersymmetry.
The Higgs mechanism had been suggested back in the sixties. And so there was a,
there was in some sense, a well-defined path to go along.
And if I were in the very first conference I ever went to in 1983 was
at the Royal society. And Stephen Hawking gave a talk very in which he said,
we will know everything by the end of the century.
And it's all any equals eight super gravity. He called it,
it was called and turned out not to be the case.
There was an example where we did think we knew where we were going and we,
the decision on the LHC was made.
And you do need to make these many years in advance. You know,
the Lac came into operation in 2008, right? 20 odd years,
nearly 30 years after the initial proposal,
the proposal for the future circular Collider would have it starting in 2050,
because you you've got to build these things.
You've got to develop the technology.
Are you saying that the large Hadron Collider didn't end up discovering the
thing it was built to discover?
No, it did the Higgs. You you're quite right.
You said at the very beginning that his primary goal was to discover the Higgs,
but it had secondary goals and there was a real feeling that it would probably
be able to, if it found the Higgs, it would probably find the,
these wind particles, because there was supersymmetric models,
which suggested that wimp particles would be in the same sort of mass range as
the Hicks. So if that wasn't the case and that wasn't the case,
they have just not, they're just not showing up. In fact,
no new particles have shown up.
So the argument for building the big circular Collider,
isn't there as strongly as it was for the LHC.
In the sense of having a whole series of particles that you think you're going
to find. Yeah. As far as I can tell, there's not.
And in fact it would be a case that we'd be building it partly in order to
actually use the Alec that they upgraded LHC.
And of course the other at sea itself still has many years left of its lifetime
to go, um,
be using it not only as a discovery machine to, to,
to actually find new things that might, might be there,
but also to ha has a high precision machine to help us understand the standard
model. And in particular,
the Higgs and the interaction the Higgs has with firmly islands,
with the things that you and I are made of the quarks and the leptons.
So to help us understand those interactions much, much better,
because another way of finding new physics is to say,
here's my standard model prediction for some very exotic process.
Then I go and measure that exotic process. And I find a difference and it's,
and the difference may only be in like the 10th decimal place.
But if you are sure about the calculations that have gone into it and sure about
the measurements, then there's, you're probing,
you're finding evidence of new physics.
Wow.
Uh, and that's one reason why you would go for a, you know,
a much more powerful machine that can probe into these new
areas, smaller length, scales, higher energy, where things might pop up.
We just don't know. It's one of the frustrating things about this.
There's two things that can go on here.
You can build a new Collider to find a new particle and have some paradigm
change, or you can build one to just slow,
fine tuning and get higher resolution and better pictures.
And then two different arguments that feels like.
Yeah, but in fine tuning, you looking for differences, right?
It's not a case of, I mean, that's what you're always probing for your,
with the way physics works, right. Is we basically,
we don't try to confirm models. We try to rule them out.
That's kind of in our heads,
we try to find deviations and that's what would this fine tuning it would be
rather than having, you know, something smashed in the face and say, here I am,
this brand new particle, look at me. I've,
I've revolutionized thing straight away.
It's a much more subtle way of doing it.
You're finding deviations from what the standard model would say. And,
and nature is can be like this. It can,
it can hide these new ingredients that make it very difficult to find.
And if we don't build something, we're not going to find them this way.
And I know it takes a long time to build these things,
but still wouldn't it make more sense to wait for the next really
paradigm break, a plausible theory, I think next to Peter Higgs,
and then start building stuff.
I think Sabine's got a very valid point here, but, you know, uh,
but, but the question also is at what stage in that process do you say,
aha, now it's time to build my new, you know,
future circular Collider. Cause there are kind of two, two aspects to it.
One is that the technology involved in the agenda on the theorist, Hey,
what do I know?
But I believe the technology involved in this is really complicated. Okay. You,
you, they're always at the cutting edge developing things.
So what the see can do right today, the back in the 1980s,
people had no idea they'd be able to do it at the level that they can do it
because technology is developed.
One of the reasons they've been able to do it is that there was always a funding
stream to help support the superconducting magnets,
to help support the development of the accelerator technology,
the detector technology, if you put that on hold, right, and say, okay,
let's just let the theorists have a go. Now for a while,
until we come up with something, what are these people going to do?
They're not going to hang around. They're not going to play, say, yeah,
this is okay. Let's just take about five years.
That's going to do something else. They're going to leave.
And the subject and the runs, the real estate, it isn't expensive subject.
It's like a polo. They will leave. And that's it, it will be the end of it.
And okay, if you, if you prepared to accept that. So be it that,
that's the nature of it.
There is one possible route through I've I've I think CERN, uh, playing this,
um, the plane for two possible scenarios here. There's another one,
which is that, although they've come out with this future Collider,
circular Collider pepper, and I personally think it's really exciting.
They've also, there's sort of at the same time, come up with a,
with another set of papers where they're looking at actually,
what can we make use of what surrounds sun moments to actually
probe different types of physics,
which would still be looking at the underlying fundamental physics of
our universe, but not requiring, you know,
really high energy particle collisions.
And this is motivated partly by the fact that we've not seen any evidence of
dark matter. So we've not seen these massive dark matter particles and maybe
what, what is actually going on in the universe,
these equivalent dark matter particles. Aren't very massive.
There may be really light and they don't interact very much with us.
In which case, having a big, heavy,
large Hadron Collider, won't be the way to see them.
We need most sophisticated. Um,
ready-made precisely made detectors to pick up some of these
lights, particles, like axions specific Axion detectors.
And so one possibility is to actually look at, um,
for a set of experiments that that could be based around
certain usings the, the,
the accelerators they've already got some using some of the facilities they've
already got. So just about better experiments under the existing they use it.
Yeah. So they use a bolt is a kind of thinking about, um,
gently place, existing experience, you know, use, use what you've got.
And then there are lots of God that was so exciting. And,
and of course you're building new things as well, but that's, that's,
that's another possible. So why have I said that?
I could imagine the community saying, okay,
let's have this period where we go that route for a little while.
Let's keep the R and D going for the, for the big accelerators.
But during that period, we can be probing testing these,
these models of weak coupling regimes, light,
dark matter particles screening mechanisms, which could account for, you know,
the, the fifth force that, that,
that it could be driving the acceleration of the universe. But meanwhile,
carry on with its R and D invest in the R and D for the future accelerators.
And then hopefully the,
either some results will out of this new set of proposals or some theoretical
developments will emerge, which say, yeah, this is the way we should be going.
And then you can sort of decide, okay, now we'll start the process on,
but there is always this risk back in the eighties,
people were absolutely certain, I think pretty sad about that.
Not absolutely, but fairly certain that wimps were the way forward.
And that supersymmetry was the way forward.
There was no question to build the large Hadron Collider after the large
electron positron combined, it was, it was just the thing to do.
And it turned out not to be right. It's Hey, who knows?
That's the excitements of many ways of working in these kinds of fields?
What would you do at,
because obviously you're biased and you're a particle physicist,
but you do live in a world where you also like hospitals and holes to be filled
and you have children are growing up in the world who need infrastructure.
How would you think the money should be spent? It's so much money.
It's just a lot of money. Um, I would spend it.
And I, because for a number of reasons, one is, uh, you know,
it's not just the UK contributing to CERN.
CERN has got 22 members. It's got, uh, I dunno, eight affiliated members.
You know, there's 30 countries here. We'll all contribute.
They'll contribute over many, many years. Okay.
It's not as if this is an immediate outlet.
So there's a dispersion of the actual finance.
Of course, hospitals need all the facilities they can, but you know,
particle physics live in hospitals right now. My, you know,
my dear father who passed away when I went to the city hospital for him to have
radiology treatment on the wall, is this amazing plaque up,
try to find an image of it that talks about the cyclotron accelerator that they
were using. And the, and that's, that was the particle physics of the forties,
thirties, forties, fifties, that is now in medicine.
The MRI scanner that was invented here at, um,
here at Nazim uses technology from the physics environment for that was
purely for research that is now been embedded in, in hospitals,
all around the world.
Medicine needs funding in its own rights. Of course it does,
but it's had so much input from fundamental ideas,
fundamental physics ideas for a start and chemistry and radio
isotopes that everywhere in medicine,
that to simply simply say, yeah, we should be putting all of this into medicine.
For example,
is not the way to make the major breakthroughs that will help people in the
future in medicine either. What makes us special?
What makes us special is our inquisitive nature.
We want to know about the universe.
We want to know about beautiful pictures and admire them.
We want to know about what makes the universe tick,
and we should have the facilities to be able to invest in all of these.
Then on the outside.
Well, because the detector here is actually for stopping the new ones,
these elementary particles, which are like electrons,
but 200 times heavier.
And they're so important because if you find a new one,
it tells you that something really high-energy has happened.
They're very difficult to create. And so you, if, if,
if a new one's detected and they're very difficult to detect,
they just shoot through all the other things we've been describing.